uh hello everybody and uh welcome to the
second uh the second talk of the day
we're uh
extremely happy to have a colleen camera
from uh
call tech university giving a giving a
talk today
so calling is a is a true foundational
expert in several areas including
behavioral game theory you know
intersections between
neuroscience and economics experimental
economics and recently using tools for
machine learning and in the mix so he's
really here to like prime our brains
to think about uh
uh learning in different ways so thank
you for so much calling for your for
participating in our workshop and now
the floor is yours
thank you georges and thanks everyone
for coming and listening um
so i'm going to talk about something
that's quite narrow but within that
narrow scope there's a lot of work and
ideas which is experimental studies
falling mostly under the rubric of
experimental economics that means we
typically explain things to people like
they're fully informed about payoffs and
we pay actual money to try to motivate
them to think carefully
and usually most of these games are
repeated stage games which means there's
a single game that's played over and
over
with the same group of people sometimes
with mixtures
what's called the stranger protocol
and there was there was a big boom in
in
this area starting around the mid 90s to
maybe 2010 and then it's kind of taper
off a lot
um because experimental economists i
think have just often moved on to other
interesting topics i'm going to talk
mostly about two things which is
reinforcement learning
coming straight from learning from
100 years ago
and this play
which is learning about what other
people are likely to do from their past
histories and then a hybrid approach
that kind of combines the two elements
called ewa that we worked on
and the goal here is to develop good
descriptive models that's it we want to
explain the data generated in the lab
and when we and occasionally i'll show
you two studies actually from field data
and
unusually
uh even among experimental economists
who are generally quite adventurous and
behavioral economists
i really like models which are
biologically implementable and therefore
consistent or can be tested with
evidence from things like eye tracking
fmri no recording of animals you're
going to see a little bit of all those
today not eye tracking
and again not most
most experimental economics labs people
come in
they see someone in the computer screen
they press a button
all we record is what they picked
sometimes we ask them questions
sometimes we record response times
and i would like to record what they're
looking at on the screen and maybe their
acceptance and all these other things
because i think their theories
need to come up frankly
uh and therefore we need some data to
pick out the best theories again this is
this idea that the theories have to be
biologically implementable and test to
test it there thereby
is not the modal
view in the field i think it should be
and
you know that's my view
okay uh we're gonna start with something
very far from that though that's but
that's cool this is a lottery game that
was played in sweden so this is field
data even though it has a lot of nice
structure
um
and um
it was in 2007 about 53 000 people
played each day and each of them chose
an integer written on that little um
card in the upper right that you see
from one to 999
and the lowest unique number
wins the price of ten thousand euros and
then there's some other constellation
prizes which we ignore
and so this is a cool game because you
have to do two things
one of which is strategic which is to
pick a low number that's easy
and to pick a unique number
right when everyone else is trying to
pick a unique number two so as you can
imagine we're going to derive a mixed
equilibrium and see what happens
okay so it turns out amazingly
some of you will know about poisson um
and ash games due to roger meyerson
because the number of players is not the
same each day if the number of players
is solemn distributed
okay it's actually not quite but it's
it's an approximation then you can
compute the mixed equilibrium and we
cannot compute it
um because of combinatorial explosion um
if the number of players is fixed like
if exactly fifty thousand fifty two
thousand people are playing we can't
compute the mixed equilibrium at least i
mean we can't maybe somebody can't
um
but if the number of players is
distributed even though
that kind of assumption is makes life
very difficult for things like auctions
in this case you can compute a mixed
real name and it has a nice very elegant
um
solution system simultaneous equations
so if n is then the mean of the poisson
distribution and p of k is the frequency
of people choosing
the number k
uh all those k values except to solve
that system of equations
and so this game is going to illustrate
short-run initial conditions like what
happens when people first play they've
never played this game before it was
just invented from thin air by a swedish
person who was a student of martin
duffenberg
and then um what happens as they learn
we're going to actually see literally
day by day data for the entire group of
people playing
okay
so in week one there's seven
observations here
seven days which is about um 200 000
observations the press on nash
prediction is the dotted line
and on the left is all the numbers up to
a hundred thousand
and on the right is the numbers from one
to ten thousand because as you can see
on the left
the game theory predicts
that 95 of the numbers approximately
will basically never be picked
numbers about 5 000
never and in fact
that's a pretty bold prediction right
nobody knew this before robert osley and
joseph long who were quite brilliant
solved it
and the people who designed the auction
didn't because they wouldn't have had so
many numbers available because a lot of
the numbers never get picked
um
however there are two deviations from
the quest on nash equilibrium
which has a really beautiful structure
the most likely number to be chosen in
equilibrium is one slightly less likely
is two then three and there's kind of a
slippery slope and then it plunges at
around fifty five hundred and thirteen
um and the numbers drop very
dramatically to essentially epsilon
okay and however the the plays of
numbers that people picked in sweden
they pick way too many small numbers
those are the great bars that are above
the dotted line right on the lower left
like a lot of people a couple hundred
people picked one and two and things
like that
and then there's a gap
from about twenty five hundred to five
thousand
at the time
uh
half of that predict distribution where
they don't choose those enough
okay q a model called cognitive
hierarchy which is as the name implies
is kind of a hierarchy of levels like
level zeros do something random or
something salient and then level ones
think they're playing level zeros and
level twos that you're playing level
ones you can fit these data pretty well
with the estimated average levels of
thinking of 1.8
okay and if you this is a rare case
where we had field data first then you
can go back and run it in the lab
and in the lab we can see if the lab is
like the field rather than the way
around it's pretty close
um and in addition we can do a few other
cool things like in the swedish data we
don't know who
you know if you know ingemar or bergman
you know played seven days in a row we
don't all we know is the population of
choices we don't know if one person
picked over and over but in the lab we
do so we can see if they if they really
makes do they have like lucky numbers
they get fixated on how do they learn
and adjust
and the lab data is very very close the
process on national room is different
because the numbers are only 199. right
because then there's fewer people
there's 26
people um
on average that's the mean of the
personal distribution the dotted line is
special nash it just kind of goes almost
straight down to 13.
and
the data are really really close
really really close right there's a
little bit
of people picking uh low numbers a
little bit too often and again there's
sort of a gap
to the middle of the distribution where
there's not enough people picking 9 10
11 and 12. so it's roughly similar in
style and this is an example of
where i think as is often the case
experimental economics lab data fits the
field data very very closely
even though it's different people these
are students at ucla and caltech
um you know they're they're playing for
smaller amount of money
etc etc um
okay
here is a gif that uh robert osling made
that shows 49 days of learning so the
and so you can see each of the
distributions won't be how the learning
works in a very um fine-grained way
people have made very few of these gifts
i think it's quite neat and you can see
day one they're really way off people
are choosing way too low
but by day 49 they're kind of filling in
the gap between blue and red
and the number of one choices gradually
goes down there's still a lot of people
picking one thinking you know i'm gonna
pick one no one else is gonna think of
that
right um nobody wins at numbers like
that the winning numbers are typically
by the way around two thousand
uh up to three thousand
okay um so learning so it turns out the
best paper on this is not ours it's by
eric moline austling and wang
um
in uh games behavior and they basically
showed that the mod best model of
population learning
is essentially an imitation model where
the it's very much like what john nash
called mass action where the the group
is a whole
ships in the direction of the last
winning number that they aim and that um
you can do that with very few parameters
and that's basically what we think is
going on again we don't have individual
level data
okay um
so to reiterate i'm going to talk about
youtube's display reinforcement um
hybrid model a number of other people i
think dan friedman is here he worked on
replicator dynamics as some beautiful
early work on that um
by the way i have a book called
behavioral game theory 2003 that has a
long chapter on learning and i try to be
very thorough on all the different
approaches people had used around that
time but that was 20 years ago somebody
should update it
um
there's a few field data i'll end with
those at the end okay so one interesting
thing is
that in at least three different areas i
know of and there may be quite a few
others
that there's been a kind of rediscovery
of a difference between learning from
experience
like
picking a number in the lottery and
figuring that you lost
and that you know the number 2614 won
versus kind of computing a strategy
value from beliefs or from comparisons
of hypothetical payoffs
that you could have had if you picked a
different number right and so that goes
under three different
rubrics the simpler type of learning is
called model free in decision
neuroscience borrowed from
cs
bartow i believe
in game theory in the 90s it was
introduced in the form of civil
reinforcement you know you pick an
action
and then you update the propensity to
pick the action based on your your
payoff
um the complex version is called
fictitious play
uh and the complex version in decision
neuro is called model based model based
just means you have an idea of what of
what all the possible actions would lead
to like you you can see the game matrix
and in 1950 there's this nash quote here
taken right for the typescript of his
thesis he talks about the mass action
interpretation of equilibrium
where
participants are supposed to accumulate
evidence about the relative advantage
and jorge weeble kind of updated that in
the 90s and wrote a similar paper
introducing what he called innovative
play so innovative play means playing a
number you never picked before based on
some model of how well it will do
okay
all right blizzard of notation uh sorry
about that but it just
it just this is what it is um
so belief models typically work like on
the left in which this is something like
the simple counting
of fictitious play
the idea is that um
you see what somebody did last time did
they pick top bottom right in a matrix
and you just count the number of times
you you can use a decay factor row to
create a sort of recency bias so the
more recent observations get more weight
and you you compute beliefs in that way
this is a very special kind of fix just
display right there are lots of variants
you could introduce
this is just counting past um behaviors
and then
[Music]
geometrically waiting
and then equation 2.9 here is that we're
going to rotations expected payoff for
person a from strategy j as a function
of these beliefs
and you can then write because the
beliefs are function of lag beliefs
right the upper left you can then write
the expectation as a function of the
lagged expectation and it has this
interesting form
so it turns out that in reinforcement
learning mostly um al roth and udo erev
working on this but many other people
like um
dan may have worked on it and um
uh
reggie sarin and others were working on
variants of reinforcement
around this period of time and
the standard model is that is that
there's a reinforcement level
that's a function of the decayed lag
reinforcement
plus an identity term which weighs the
payoff of the strategy if that's the one
you chose
and otherwise there's no reinforcement
this this is just one vanilla version
there's a little
feature
secret which has the the expected of um
payoffs from fictitious play and the
reinforcement levels as a
um
both
as
boundary cases you can just write an
equation like this 2.2
and we just substitute a for attractions
and the idea is that
is that the attraction of strategy j
is multiplied by a weight delta
even if you didn't choose it
right and if you did choose it the
weight is delta plus one minus delta
which just adds up to one you so you
fully weight
receive payoffs from strategy you chose
and you weight by delta
strategies that you didn't choose the
so-called innovative play model based
etc okay and then we can use delta to
kind of tell us
how strong is a pure reinforcement
effect where strategy is reinforced
versus specific just display model based
type of typically we get deltas around
0.5
but it varies
and also the the identification of
parameters is as you can see there's a
lot of things multiplied together and
then also these attractions are then fed
into a soft max
function
okay uh so here's some neural evidence
without much background this is a paper
by lucho zhu who is
a postdoc of ming soo who's there at
berkeley
she is my academic grandchild his name
was was my
student at caltech
and what they did was to play a game
where you could estimate the
reinforcement signal and the belief
signal
and the signal from the hybrid ewa model
so in each you know there's a time
series of these numbers
and then you look for areas of the brain
that have
bold signal which is blood flow activity
that's correlated with the time series
of the behavior this is called brain
behavior computational
event related fmri
and what you see is
that in putamen
which is on the left which is part of
what's so-called basal ganglia reward
circuitry
if you get um neural betas
that is the blood flow signal is
associated with the number that we think
people are computing for all three
models however in anterior cingulate
cortex marked this purple line
which is an important region involved in
conflict uh conflict and cognitive
control and error monitoring and sort of
thinking a little harder about something
that's more complex
you can see that there's a signal
that rather activity in acc is
correlated with the belief-based
computation and with the hybrid but not
with reinforcement learning so
reinforcement learning
and belief based learning are both in
putamen
but it is absent in anterior cingulate
so if you answer the question is there a
is there a region which does not compute
reinforcement but computes other things
that's the answer question
uh calling yes sorry i have a question
so
uh so here how do you know when the
experiment happens that like an agent
let's say uses reinforcement or like use
belief based
so which i presume this is what you're
matching right you say like look so
so somebody looks at the behavioral data
coming from the agent somehow like
playing a game again and again and then
you do something like machine learning
to estimate like a best fit of of those
parameters yeah yeah
yes except usually
this study this is pretty old as
economic study goes as 10 years old yeah
exactly so what happens is
you take the data from behavior from
what they did and then you fit a model
or fit multiple models as if you don't
even have the brain data
and then we take the best fitting model
for each person
and you say you know like what areas of
the brain have a time series
of some number like what choice you made
or the probability that you were using
reinforcement learning that's correlated
with the behavioral model
exactly it's a this this process was
essentially invented by john o'doherty
who's my colleague here about 2005 and
has really swept through neuroscience
um
and i and somebody should get really
is that if you really understand the
behavior first
with this computational model which
could include machine learning by the
way we've often that's often used if you
have lots of areas of the brain you want
to pick out just a few you know
regularization is absolutely the way to
go and that's been very very popular
sometimes called mvpa
so our view is if you really understand
the behavior computationally and you
really fit the behavior pretty well
then you're going to find interesting
things in the brain
and if you don't really understand the
behavior computationally it's going to
be a mess
right and again this is i mean i'm kind
of an evangelist for this viewpoint
right but it's been very successful we
think we think
okay hi um yeah another question
could you possibly define at a high
level what are the key differences
between reinforcement learning and
belief based learning and what are those
two are because at this point i'm not
okay oh great i'm really glad you left
is that quite central thank you for
asking so
the key is in something like the lottery
game
right reinforcement means i played the
number 82 and i got zero
and so i do not reinforce 82 and i don't
do anything with the other numbers
in belief-based learning i picked number
82 and i got zero but i know that the
winner was 2500.
so i say to myself gee if i pick 2500 i
would have had 2 000 10 000 euros so i i
then uh i then update the the value
of choosing 2500
by delta times 10 000 euros
and that's mathematically the same as if
i'm forming a belief about what everyone
else will do
and then i'm learning to best respond to
that belief
does that help
so maybe uh just just to give it like
also like a comment uh i think in the
the reinforcement learning setting is
like closer to our bonded setting so we
only get access to the uk from the from
the action that you see
whereas in the belief space it's
actually access to the full vector
right
good perfect yeah that's absolutely
right exactly it's as if you're doing a
bandit task
and you get a you get a payoff from the
banner you selected and then you also
find out some information could be
partial information
about what the other bandit rewards were
okay
okay um
uh
i'm just going to skate through this one
this is actually
data from a paradigm in which you
implant an electrode in a monkey's brain
and record individual neurons firing
from different regions and all you need
to see in this picture is that ao
these are these are essentially firing
rates um
ao which is actual payoffs when the
monkey is looking at the actual payoff
they received from playing a game it's
basically a hydro seeker
game
that the the neural firing rate about
0.2 stack and
200 milliseconds after they get the
neural firing rate in an area called
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex which is
here and orbital frontal cortex which is
above your eye sockets hence orbital
these the blue and purple lines go up
that means those neurons in that area
are firing
and in addition if the when the monkey
looks at a hypothetical path it did not
receive like if i made a different
choice what would i have gotten
right that's what a belief-based model
would do right you're building up a
belief about the other player and you
think oh that other player did this if i
had chosen differently i would have done
better or worse
and the neurons also fire that's that's
orange and red they also fire but almost
almost
only half as much
in response to the hypothetical payoffs
so again the key idea here is very very
simple in in off-the-shelf straight
reinforcement learning the only thing
that's reinforced is what you actually
picked
and so there's no need for the animal to
look at the hypothetical payoffs but if
you want to learn faster
like in a belief-based way than the
hypothetical parent
[Music]
information
and again that's model-based
uh which is this play has that implicit
assumption and innovative play from
libel
okay so the hypothetical paths are
attended to in the monkey brain yes
just a small point i'm not sure if you
can do anything about this but sometimes
we do have some slight delay from you on
your end
like from the wi-fi
uh i mean for the most part i think it
works fine uh but okay i'll just all to
talk slower or say try to
say less
i'm saying that if
maybe maybe another approach that like
if the problem persists or becomes
harder maybe we'll ask you like it may
be uh uh turn off your screen and we can
still hear you but maybe not see you but
we'll still be okay let's do that yeah
okay maybe that will help um
okay here's a another game that's going
to show us learning and show us some
model comparison this is i call this
price matching with loyalty rewards it's
just it's kind of like a vertron
competition there's two players
they simultaneously without
communicating pick a price integer price
from 80 to 200 those are pennies
and then the price they both receive is
the minimum
right so it's like an industrial regime
in which you have to match the other
guy's price
um
but the low price firm earns that number
p which is the minimum plus a reward r
and the high price firm earns p mysr
so the the conflict here
is similar to um
the lowest integer game
the two players together want the price
to be high they want to collude and try
to pick 200 but
if you the other person picks 200 you
pick 199
you get 199 plus the r reward and a
typical r value in their original paper
uh they they play with various values of
r and their typical r value for example
is 15.
right so there's a very strong incentive
to undercut the competitor but if
everyone undercuts everyone else you can
imagine the national equilibrium if
players are perfectly selfish is 80. you
should just have this race to the bottom
where everyone is constantly
undercutting and even though they end up
worse off than if they could somehow
collude at 200
um that's what happens so let's see what
happens in the data here's empirical
frequencies okay
so on the x-axis the front axis
is number of categories
from 80 80 is it is a distinct category
up to
and then the periods they played 10
times so the periods go toward the back
from one to one to nine to and ten
okay and then the frequencies are on the
vertical axis
so what happens is
they start out choosing a lot of people
choose 150
and some choose 200. those are the most
common choices in period one right the
purple bar and then the light lilac bar
nobody picks 80.
right but gradually what happens is
the high numbers disappear right there's
a few people this may only be a couple
of people picking 200 later but
basically the the system drifts downward
after about five periods
the modal choice is orange which is
around 125
and um by period eight seven eight nine
ten
um eighty percent of the people in the
last period are choosing the unique nash
equilibrium
right so this is a oh this is also an
exemplar of something we often see in
experimental economics which is the data
start at far from equilibrium
in this case at 200 which is this kind
of like
artificial cooperative outcome that is
not sustainable and then it drifts in
this case in 10 periods
you get eighty percent conformity with
the unique
nash equilibrium of 80.
okay and so we're going to try to
understand
our approach and the virtue of many
people at this time was to try to
explain every single person's
observation every person
period of data
rather than just moments of the data
although of course that's can be quite
useful too so we're going to try to
produce a model
which um
reproduces these data and by the way we
in our work we almost always used
in sample validation and then um or in
sample fitting and then a hold out test
sample so that we're since a lot of
these models have a lot of degrees of
freedom we're trying to control for
degrees of freedom as well as using
bic aic measures yes question
yeah uh what what happens when the
players
report the same
price
sorry i missed that part um oh you know
i think then they just get p
in other words i think nobody gets
nobody gets gets r and nobody loses r
then how is that in equilibrium
oh
uh i see never mind
yeah yeah oh you mean how how do they
get stuck at 80 yeah because you don't
want to go above right
because if the other guy said 80 and you
go above the price is still 80.
yeah yeah you could you couldn't figure
it out yeah um it does depend on r if r
is very small
then um
the results can be different like if r
is less than one
all right so so that
and actually that's a that's a a feature
not a bug so by varying r if you think
about the game two a little bit as long
as r is above one
by varying r
the nash equilibrium doesn't change at
all
it's always 80.
but when you make r like 80 which they
did in some of the experimental sessions
to
the movement toward equilibrium is much
faster so a lot of these things which in
equilibrium shouldn't actually make a
difference will make a difference in the
pace of learning as you know i mean as
you can imagine
that's why we should not just study
equilibrium but
other processes like learning
okay so that's the empirical frequency
again here's a belief based model so
this is fictitious play
and it does a pretty good job on the
basic trends it's much more orderly of
course looking than the data because
there's no sampling error
um the main flaw with the beliefs based
model is
is the the expected payoffs from the
belief based only vary in a smallish
range and so in a soft max with a fixed
inverse temperature parameter
it's really hard to get really high
probabilities you know it's like 80
chance
of picking 80. so it doesn't quite
generate tall enough
bar charts at the bottom but it does
capture the basic trend pretty nicely
um so i i have a short question so for
the this belief based model
so your your model has a quite a few
parameters so
you think so this uh so i could i could
imagine several different instantiation
as a an example of a belief based model
is is this for example like exactly
fictitious play or like uh
do you remember it's it's it's a
geometrically weighted fictitious
display food and levine's book has a
little discussion of this yeah okay and
i guess the choice of this uh
discounting does not really affect the
the qualitative results that you're
showing us right
uh actually it's pretty important here
because you have to
um
in these data it looks like people are
are decaying
beliefs a lot
right right because
in the belief based model you're going
to think oh this guy's going to pick
200.
but after after one period they don't
pick 200 anymore so in order for your
beliefs to kind of
match what people actually do and then
generate good choices and then fit the
people's choices
you need a pretty um
decay rate that's much less than once
okay so so in this case your belief
model is the best
possible the best uh
matching of your model with let's say
delta equals to one
and and the other processor okay exactly
so yeah essentially it's delta equals
one and then all the other parameters
are inherited
yeah exactly so our general approach is
to have a pretty a pretty busy
family of models with different
parameters and then you just clamp like
belief bases just clamping delt equal to
one
right and reinforcement learning is just
clamping delt equal to zero
yeah okay
um so there's belief base we just saw
this is choice reinforcement with payoff
variability which means that you you
kind of scale payoffs but by variance
which seems to often be important and
seems to correspond in our processes too
of um
what's called efficient coding
and
this is terrible
because
in choice reinforcement if you never
picked 80
it's hard to learn to pick 80. unless
you add in something else that's a bit
ad hoc like
um spreading the reinforcement to
neighboring what's called stimulus
generalization and animal learning
spreading reinforcement to neighboring
numbers right so you reinforce 150 but
you also reinforce 149 151
and so what happens is the data move
down away from the high numbers but way
too slowly
and it doesn't build up the choices of
80 it does build up choices of 80 from
nothing to something but it does so very
very slowly and so by the last period
um only 15 of the people play 80 and in
the data it's 80
so reinforcement learning this is often
the case it moves in the right direction
but it's just too slow
it's just too slow and again we're
trying to not just say simulate
thousands of reinforcement drills and
fit it and look at the data we're trying
to actually match period by period like
after 10 periods what do people do what
does reinforcement say
they would be doing
under optimized parameters optimized for
a fit
so reinforcement goes in the right
direction but it's just not
quantitatively close
and this is a version of ewa that has a
few extra twists
um and that does great and again it's
sort of exploiting
the fact that it
it um it uses the engine of belief
learning so that you can learn to play
low numbers even though you never played
them before right which reinforcement
can't learn
um
but it
because of the way the scaling is done
it's not in standard fictitious display
it's um it also can produce really hard
like a hard stick where a lot of people
are picking one number after 10 periods
which is what happens in the data
the convergence of national global is
very reliable
if you do it session after session
you'll see the same thing with different
groups of people
okay
uh okay um
uh next topic strategic teaching
um
um
so one of the things that always haunted
us that was really kind of embarrassing
was
these simple models like reinforce
reinforcement learning was developed to
understand animal behavior
uh including humans
and fictitious play was designed to
understand convergence to games
to give us a way to kind of think about
almost like a mental to tunnel
originally
but neither of them really take
seriously the fact that you're playing
another human being who's thinking and
learning
right so you could apply fictitious play
belief formation to learning about
states of nature right like to learning
an abandoned task
where the banner rewards are not
produced by human beings behavior so
we really need some theory i think in in
which the fact that humans know they're
playing other humans who are learning is
part of the theory
which again somewhat embarrassingly is
not true in the reinforcement and um
uh and even the ewa implementations
right they were kind of like it was you
know i don't know i'm not that
embarrassed but um it was a missing
ingredient
so uh fudemorgan levine and later joel
watson and others
developed quite a bit of interesting
theory on this and they coined the term
strategic teaching for when an agent's
actions create an immediate payoff
as well as influencing the learning of
another agent right like if you think
the other agent is learning from
fictitious play you want to like create
a belief about what you'll do
which will give you a bigger payoff in
the future
okay and the paper by hampton
uh beau sartson o'doherty and pnes
actually they call it influence value
which is the nice term also the
influence value is the special component
of future payoffs from this teaching
influence
right and they actually have evidence
for that in in the brain and it's a very
beautiful paper um
um
and also this can help us understand so
many things like bluffing right like if
you're a really good poker player
you want to create almost like a persona
you know where you're playing in a
particular way to get somebody to think
that you're going to continue to do that
in the future or think about like a con
or a sting right where you want to
um
often in these long what's called a long
con you actually enables you get
you get people to make bets where they
win some money from you
and they think we're going to win even
more in the future and in the future you
create this thing and you take their
money and they get nothing so this idea
of strategic teaching is so interesting
it's so interesting and it came to game
theory
um quite late
you know and and
there hasn't been much research on it so
sadly i'm just going to show you one
study of ours from
quite a while ago from 10 years ago
okay
so this is a study about what's called a
repeated trust game tragically we did
not use the word trust
in the title of our paper
which was a colossal mistake in 1988 uh
because later people came along study
trust games but it's a repeated trust
game you'll see why i might walk through
the details so the idea is that there's
a single borrower and then a series of
eight lenders
and each lender just plays one period
but they know all the previous history
okay
and the idea is the lender can give you
no loan and then nothing happens
everyone gets 10. that's the bottom row
of this table
or the lender can lend
and if you repay the lender gets 40
and you get 60 the borrower
but
if you default the lender loses 100
and a so-called normal type borrower
gets 150. so there's a big motivation to
default
and final twist is there's two types of
borrowers there's what we call honest
borrower and the honest borrower
basically gets zero if they default so
this is somebody who has a conscience or
feels guilt or something like that
okay so if if you're suppose you're a
lender and you're in position number six
again you're gonna do eight of these in
a row you've seen that you've seen five
times that there were loans and
repayments
but you know that the the
eight is the last period
and so there's a fair chance that in the
last period in the eighth they're going
to default
do you land or not and it depends upon
what is called reputation which is
basically the perceived probability
based on the history
that the borrower is an honest type
right because the honest type in fact i
think the way we did the experiments the
honest types
they were just instructed you have to
always repay you have to always repay
um
it's a dominant strategy because it
doesn't you don't get any bonus from
defaulting
um
and so the reputation is going to be the
probability that you're honest based on
what you did in the past and we did this
in the 80s because there was a real boom
and interest in these reputation
modeling in repeated games it was an
extremely interesting topic it never got
much traction in decision neuroscience
or
even too much in experimental economics
although we worked on it and then john
cagle wrote a couple of beautiful papers
on entry deterrence which is a very
classic
problem in um in a dust organization and
so there were there were six or eight
really beautiful papers on this very
prominently published this one in 1988
was in econometrica and then
somehow interested in this class of
games just fell off even though i think
they're extremely fascinating
okay so this is a sketch of the
sequential equilibrium the idea is that
remember on the on the
the x-axis is time one to eight
nine is basically after the period is
over
and the y-axis is a probability of
honest
being an honest type so the types are
drawn each sequence of eight like each
time on the computer screen it says okay
you're on you're a regular x type or it
says oh you're a y type you have to
always repay
okay and it's independent each time
and in this case the probability of an
honest type the prior which is known by
everybody is one-third
is one-third
okay and so the way it works is
in the first
three periods
if you're a regular type person who's
tempted to default but but if you
default early you'll no won't get any
more loans right you won't get a flow of
these
payoffs of 60. so you should always
repay that's a one always repay that's
one always repay that's a one starting
in period four
you should pay back with probability
0.81
and you should default 90 of the times
if you do that
if you do repay the posterior
probability that you're honest goes up
right because 90 of those people default
so the probability goes up which induces
more loans and and gradually what
happens is as you as you go along in
this later part of the sequence of eight
you should increase the chance of um
defaulting and decrease the chance of
paying back and if you get to the eighth
period
and you get a loan you should definitely
default
and amazingly if you care to go back and
read our paper
the data look quite a bit like this
after people have
played these sequences maybe 10 or 20 or
30 times
so even though the mathematics that
generates these predictions is very
non-obvious i hope you can get the
intuition that that you're probably
default should be going up toward the
end right because the influence value
reduces right because you only have a
couple of periods left very much like
repeated person's llama right you often
see full cooperation until the last
three periods or something like that
um
okay and so um we developed a different
version of strategic teaching that has
two extra ingredients one is alpha is
there's a percentage of sophisticated
borrowers
borrowers
who think that they're teaching the the
adaptive learners they think each of
these
lenders
is learning using awa and i'm going to
kind of teach them what to expect in the
future right
um
and the other term is epsilon which is
the weight you put on future payoffs
which is influence value
right so this is really a different
model here
the sophisticated borrowers
think what should i do now to change
their beliefs about me for the next
person so i can make more money in the
future
and it sounds a lot like reputation
building but it it's essentially the
same intuition just in a different
mathematical framework
okay and this is eight separate
experimental sessions
with some variation in the the prior the
probably of an honest type person
existing and in the payoff so
you would expect some
wiggle room and the results are pretty
messy i must admit um
epsilon in about half the sessions is
very close to one
which means they're really looking ahead
at all the entire
future plays but in some of the other
sessions it's quite low
and you know we don't yeah we don't know
if we're really not identifying this
number very well or there are
differences in groups of people probably
some of each and the alpha value except
for 0.7 which is very high
is usually around it's either very small
or 20 or 30. so in a bunch of sessions
it's around one-third in other sessions
it's around two-thirds that means that a
bunch of the borrowers are not doing
this very sophisticated
look ahead
okay
um
one more fun thing
related to learning but i'm not going to
show you the behind-the-scenes learning
center we also have a beautiful study
thanks to chris martin
and humans and chimpanzees
these are humans in
a game preserve in africa where
uh chris martin's
advisor uh matsuzawa sensai who is a
very very famous primatologist in japan
he basically oversees chimps in nagoya
in a a lab
and
they also have access to chimps in the
wild in um
um i think it's in benin or gabon or
some place in west africa
okay
and so this is a this is a hide and seek
game
right so one person wants to match
they're going to just just use left and
right screens you see that you see the
chimpanzee right he's looking at left
and right boxes they just use a touch
screen and they press left or right
the chimps are very smart we share 90
8.7 percent of our genes with them
they're they're our closest can in the
animal kingdom genetically and not only
that and we're their closest kin so
chimpanzees are closely related more
closely to us
genetically than to orangutans
um
and so they they can perform tasks i
think similar to maybe three or
four-year-old children except for
speaking
they're pretty they have pretty good
working memory and everything and
they're very trainable
um
okay so each of these dots is one person
each of these triangles rather their
triangles
and what this is going to show us is
the probability that the match the
matcher chooses right
the right box on the x-axis the probably
the matcher the mismatcher chooses right
on the y-axis
okay
so in this particular game the payoffs
are asymmetric so the nash equilibrium
is that the matcher should choose right
50 of the time
the mismatchers should choose right 80
percent of the time that's the mixed
unique mixed equilibrium
okay i'm sorry i'm not showing you the
game matrix
and what you see is
the chimps which are yellow
um
and are very close to the nash
equilibrium
right they're basically around 50
matching choosing right 80
mismatches choosing right and the humans
we have two samples of humans which is
japanese people in nagoya and africans
shown in this picture here and the
africans by the way were paying for
money and the money we paid was they're
they're not well paid they're low income
so the money we paid was similar was
similar to like two days wages so
they're highly motivated and the chimps
play for um
food rewards
food warts okay and um
what you see is that the chimps are
closer to excluding than the humans
humans are basically just around 50 50.
they're they're a little bit in the
direction of the nash equilibrium but
they're close to just 50 50 matching
and if you take just the chimp data we
have three different parameters versions
of the game so they're naturally a shift
from 50
mismatch or right to 75 and then to 80.
the squares of the nash equilibrium and
the
triangles are the average chimp data
averaged across six chimpanzees and i
claim
that this is the best adherence to nash
equilibrium
in a mixed game mixed equilibrium game
ever seen
among any species
it's really close don't you think
it's really close
um and there's there's only one
deviation out of the six comparisons
right three games
and then two distinct strategic roles
match your mismatcher there's six
possible numbers
only one of them is off
by about 0.10
right they're playing right a little
less often than predicted and the rest
are within 0.0101
right and if you if you look at our
paper it turns out the reason is the
chimps learn
better they basically respond to the
previous history
more than the humans do and again we
don't think it's just motivation because
the african humans are playing for a lot
of money somehow their chimps just get
into gear and
our papers is a kind of real science
paper
um and we talk about matsuzawa has this
idea what's called the cognitive trait
of hypothesis basically
when kids are two or three years old
they start to play with other kids and
they learn language
and that sort of like crowds out
other abilities whereas the chimps
continue to play hide and seek
and other games that involve status
um including something called sneaky
population you can guess what that is
the chimps continue to play hide and
seek type games they're not talking to
each other and they're not cooperating
what they're doing is playing hide and
seek
so they have more evolutionary history
that's the
idea um
finally here's another learning of the
field paper it's basically an
agent-based model of drug trafficking
and all you need to know really is that
the data are in these um red lines and
then the model is it's a very complex
model but it does have ewa learning so
the drug traffickers and then law
enforcement both learn from drug busts
like you know where to avoid trafficking
your drugs
and this is a map i just love this
graphic it's very busy obviously but
this is guatemala honduras nicaragua
costa rica and panama
and here's the cute thing about that
here's the paper
uh there's one other author who's not
listed here
think about why that might be
they don't want to die
okay that's it
thanks very much
okay we're opening up four questions
what do you see as the future directions
of this line of research and what are
the kind of
goals or applications yeah good so one
thing is i would love to see more
applications to field data um
again even just a simple distinction
between reinforcement of what you
actually did what you personally
experienced versus something you you you
hypothetically kind of you think about
um could be quite important for example
in um
my colleague lawrence gin and nick
barbara's who are finance professors
have a paper applying this to stock
market investment and it seems like this
model free model based distinction
is quite useful there and explaining
some things that are puzzling about um
stock price
investment um
i think the you know
industrial organization when you have
entry into a new
there actually are a couple of papers on
entry into new businesses and you know
what businesses succeed and fail and how
does learning work would be very
interesting um
probably the biggest
really embarrassing omission is that
in these class of games every game that
i showed you it's the same game and
every period you make a choice
and the choice generates a payoff
but that choice doesn't change the game
configuration at all
right so a much more interesting general
model is when
the you know the choice you make in the
um for example in the cocaine
traffickers suppose there's a big drug
bust
what happens with a big drug bust is the
traffickers lose the law enforcement
wins because they get bigger budgets and
in addition some law is passed it
changes all the structure of the games
right um
and we have rosemarie eagle has a and i
think reinhardt zelda have a couple of
papers on this but we rarely studied
that experimental economics where the
the the action choices everybody makes
actually then changes the structure of
the game
like a new entrant occurs or there's a
regulation or some tax
um and i know that in um
in q learning and lots of other areas in
cs that's more like the standard model
right in other words you're interested
in not just rewards but state
transitions so an action will generate a
state transition and that's something we
just haven't tackled
and the second thing is um
getting back to reputation so i think
the reputation modeling
is it's very well known in economics and
it has worked out a lot of applications
for things like entry there's been a
little bit of work in political science
think about conflict like putin in
ukraine right is
you know what type of reputation are
people trying to build for for future
you know for future that has future
consequences um
is you know how does irrationality enter
into that um if putin is really sick as
has been rumored so that the time
horizon is short you know that's like
the eighth period of the lending game
right who knows what might happen um
and there hasn't been any decision
neuroscience i think we're going to
start to work on that this year to try
to see is it
our view is if we understand the
behavior and the behavior is interesting
we're gonna we're gonna find something
interesting in the brain
something kind of clear and something
interesting
um
and we also have
i know most you aren't is in the brain
as i am but we also have a lot of causal
tools like if you can identify a brain
area like dorsal medial prefrontal
cortex which computes influence value
that's what john doherty found
we can actually up and down regulate
that with electricity
with something called
tdcs transcranial direct current and we
can basically create more activity in
that region or less activity and we
might be able to make people more
reputation-minded
or less reputation-minded
and that would be just interesting to do
it's sort of like another check that the
model's on the right track not just
computationally
in terms of the numbers but also in
in accounting for brain activity and
causal effects
um
another thing a number of open entrance
individual differences i'm not that
interested in individual differences um
you know are there people who
probably iq
is is associated with with being more
model based and being more in the
direction of fictitious play
uh there may be differences in life
cycle you know like
adolescents start to become more
sensitive
because just as play like
you know after being reinforcement when
they're little or something like that um
and quite quite a bit of that's
going on in neuroscience using not using
the fictitious play and reinforcement
structure by using model free model
based
uh other other questions
i i have a question uh actually about uh
these parameters
so yeah
is there are these parameters persistent
uh
in regards to a single individual from
one type of game to another or are they
dependent on the actual game that i'm
playing so let's say
if i would play rock paper scissors and
then you know i come back to your lab
and and i play like coordination game
right would you strongly you know would
you expect me that that you have this i
would have the same feed and then have
people actually studied this
oh yeah yeah no that's a very good
question yes um
um in psychology that's basically called
states and traits which basically means
are you you know are you a certain type
of person and you play every game in a
certain way like are you a fictitious
play type or your reinforcement type um
or it could be that that different games
illicit you know behavior which is more
just as play-like or more
um
reinforcement like uh we've studied it a
little bit we um
um
we haven't studied very much a few
people have tackled that you know you
get a group of people they play three or
four different games and you see general
tendencies mostly there's some general
tendency but it's kind of modest
um in other words the correlations the
types
across measured types across different
games or parameter correlations like
delta might be like 0.3
but that's true of a lot of
psychological traits you know they're
not always
extremely they're not extremely
correlated across
domains
um
thank you
i'm wondering in the um
monkey hide and seek example you showed
um
it seems like still the humans are
playing uh very similarly and i guess is
there any way to actually define a
solution concept mathematically
that would predict how humans would play
and would that be really
would that like solution concept have a
notion of stationarity just like the
nash equilibrium does or do you have to
like
consider those modeling those problems
through the dynamics
um oh i'm sorry i'm not i'm not 100
percent absorbing your i i have to go to
another call
because i'm not 100 absorbing your
question um
generally we haven't explored that a lot
there's a lot of theory like food and
levine have a beautiful book on this
which is now 20 years old
there's a lot of theory answering that
trying to answer that question which is
what
what learning dynamics generate what
types of equilibrations
um
and
um i think it's the case that fictitious
play will generally converge
to
certain sets of equilibria again it may
not maybe a broader set than nash
um
and uh we i haven't really studied that
that i mean it's not my comparative
advantage to study that problems other
people other people are much better at
figuring that out
um
i mean i i will say just kind of
intuitively that in almost all the data
sets we've used which ranges from a
bunch that you saw today including
chimpanzees um
and field data like the lowest integer
game in sweden and then this um cocaine
trafficking game and we have some data
in um
from movie um
disclosure of movie reviews and
we have a lot of types of data and
there's almost there's almost no game so
simple that people will play equilibrium
from right from the beginning unless
they're very sophisticated and maybe
they talk about it or something like
that
and there's no game so complicated you
can't get close to a collaboration even
with a loopy game which
is quite difficult to solve
mathematically
um so that it's just a kind of folk
theorem basically that
that the forces of equilibration are are
pretty strong again again there may be
like
diabolical examples like shapley
introduced a game
uh with a mixed equilibrium and three
strategies which justice play would just
cycle around and that that basically
caused game theorists
for
20 years to not
to sort of give up on fictitious play
until it got me
the debate got reopened by dave krebs
and drew fuhrenberg and a lot of others
i wish i had a more satisfying answer
but it's just it's just something i
don't know
i don't know much about
it's lunch time yes it is lunch time so
once again let's thank colin
thank you very much
thanks everyone